the flooded arkema chemical plant
northeast of houston could see more
explosions over the next few days part
of the facility in crosby texas caught
fire after the valves in a storage
container burst the plant's owner says
eight other containers filled with
chemicals are ready to blow david begno
is at the harris county emergency
operations center in houston with the
latest on this david good morning
gail good morning with everything that's
going on here in houston they're keeping
an eye on the next hurricane irma but
the radar that matters this morning is
the one over houston and thankfully it
is clear look there were no explosions
overnight but as you said gail more
appear to be imminent we told you about
those 15 sheriff's deputies yesterday
that were treated at the hospital after
breathing in some of the fumes following
that explosion they have been released
from the hospital that's the good news
and this morning the federal agency the
u.s chemical safety board
has launched a federal investigation
into what's going on there
from above the arkema chemical plant we
saw a fire continuing to burn thursday
morning hours after it began
by late afternoon the flames appeared to
be out but arkema's warning there is
evidence suggesting that other trailers
will soon burn satellite images from
before and after the flooding really
tell the story the water knocked out
power that's needed to prevent unstable
organic peroxide compounds from
overheating and catching fire we have
been in a defensive posture holding a
perimeter around the facility
to make sure that our citizens are safe
and that our environment is protected
the plan now
let it burn
authorities evacuated people within a
mile and a half radius of the facility
this should have never happened
they should have had backups
in case they lost power
the company did have backup generators
but it's unclear whether they were
protected if you need an interview sir
excuse me we have tried
we tried to get in touch with your
company yesterday repeatedly company
executive richard renard agreed to take
some of our questions one-on-one but
admitted he didn't have all the answers
including this one from a local resident
were the generators elevated
i don't know the location specifically i
just don't know the specifics of where
the generators happen to be located an
inspection last year by the occupational
safety and health administration found
10 serious violations ultimately
resulting in more than ninety one
thousand dollars in fines but a former
osha official tells cbs news none of
that would probably be relevant to the
situation we're dealing with now
mr renard tells us the company had more
than one backup plan two three and four
and they all failed now listen this may
be controversial but the local sheriff
here in harris county says from
everything he's been told
what is burning from the area of that
explosion is non-toxic in fact he's told
the public
that experts have told him it is no
different than standing around a
campfire
maurice okay david begno we shall see